ja ich glaube dass sie die sogenannte
walkenes oder alles was wir darunter
subsumieren und auch die
Identitätspolitik die damit reinspielt
unterm Strich unsere Freiheit gefährdet
ich sehe aber trotzdem eine ganze Reihe
positive Entwicklung ins auch wenn wir
gerade wieder diskutieren über einen
blackfacing Vorwurf gegenüber eines
Karnevalisten der von Boris rein
empfangen wurde es gab eine vergangenen
Woche drei interessante Meldungen in dem
Zusammenhang die surfin Krone besser die
Hamilton beispielsweise weigert sich
weiter für ihren Verband anzutreten wenn
dieser die Planken Transgender
Regelungen umsetzt wonach auch
biologische Männer in der
frauenkategorie antreten dürfen wir
hatten den Musiker Helge Schneider bei
einem Talkshow Auftritt vergangene Woche
der den Vorwurf der kulturellen
aneigungen Musik ähm kommentierte damit
das interessiert mich einen Scheißdreck
außerdem zeigt eine jüngste Umfrage von
intertest die Map im Auftrag vom des WDR
das ein Großteil oder der größte Teil
der Menschen sich nicht fürs Gendern
interessiert und auch wir müssen da
aktuell mit und haben jetzt diese Woche
von sie zu einem Buch veröffentlicht mit
dem Thema die walkeness Illusion wenn
Political Correctness die Freiheit
gefährdet und ich hoffe dass unser Buch
aber genauso auch die Vorkommnisse in
der vergangenen Woche ein bisschen zu
einer Konter Revolution in dem ganzen
einladen einige Beispiele aufgezählt wo
sehen sie in welchem Aspekt die Freiheit
besonders gefährdet an wo fühlen sie
sich in ihrer Freiheit ein ich
persönlich ich persönlich für mich
aktuell noch nicht in meiner Freiheit
eingeschränkt ich glaube man muss auch
differenzieren wir haben auch lange über
den Untertitel wenn political correkt
ist die Freiheit gefährdet diskutiert
wir sagen ja aktuell nicht das ist quasi
dass wir jetzt in einer unfreien
Gesellschaft leben aber es gibt
Tendenzen wo man zumindest sieht das
dass diese Tendenzen gegen eher die
freiheitliche aufgeklärte Gesellschaft
sich richten und ähm erkennen dass das
diese diese diese Wirkung ist Debatte
also ich stehe ja nicht morgens auf und
sage ja heute beschäftige mich wieder
mit dem Thema dass diese Worte von mir
quasi funktioniert oder für uns
inszenieren alle möglichen Bereich
unsere Gesellschaft vor
Natur beispielsweise in der Niederlanden
wurde jetzt kürzlich ein Stück abgesagt
weil nur Männer in diesem Stück spielen
sollten laut Samuel Backe das Stück
geschrieben hat genau wir haben Themen
wieder unternehmerischen Freiheit
beispielsweise wo irgendwelche diversity
beauftragten den ganzen Laden
durcheinander würfeln und irgendwie
Unruhe reinbringen und wir haben eben
auch nicht zuletzt hat mir auch nicht
vergessen das ist ein bisschen auch ihr
Thema wir hatten vor Silvester den 29
seitigen sprachkatalog an die Berliner
Polizei die jetzt und wirklich andere
Probleme hat als er sich jetzt 29 Seiten
damit auseinandersetzen was dürfen sie
eigentlich noch sagen was nicht
vor 50 Jahren noch normalerweise sagen
wir jetzt nicht mehr die Menschheit muss
ich halt auch weiterentwickeln denken
sie da irgendwelche Gefahren ja
natürlich also Weiterentwicklung das ist
ja natürlich weiterentwickelt ja klar
muss ich alles weiterentwickeln und da
darf man auch keine Scheuklappen haben
die Dinge entwickeln sich weiter aber es
muss eben natürlich Weiterentwicklung
aus der Gesellschaft heraus für die
Mehrheit der Gesellschaft sein und wenn
das was Sie beschrieben haben lieber
Krischke das sind ja oft Sachen die
werden von der kleinen Minderheit
eigentlich der großen Mehrheit der
Gesellschaft aufgezogen und gehen
eigentlich an den Problemen der Menschen
vor Ort vorbei sie sagen richtig ich bin
ja Polizisten haben hier ein richtig
harten Job der ist hier richtig viel zu
tun in dieser Stadt nicht nur in der
Silvesternacht sondern Tag für Tag jede
Nacht jeden Tag auch die Rettungskräfte
von Feuerwehr und Sanitär ja und wir
stehen an deren Seite und wenn sie nicht
bevormunden mit Sprachregelungen oder
mit dem Antidiskriminierungsgesetz dass
sie nachweisen müssen dass sie die
beweislands haben dass sie nicht
diskriminiert haben ja wir müssen doch
erstmal vorurteilsfrei an dem rangehen
blackfazit bei einer Karnevalsparty
hätten sie das Fisch falsch halten Sie
das für okay Gendern ja oder nein
das Thema Gendern ist eins wo ich sagen
muss Werder werden so sprechen möchte
der kann so sprechen aber er muss sich
bewusst sein dass er an der Mehrheit der
Menschen in diesem Land einfach vorbei
redet und da wurde genannt sozusagen aus
vom Staat herauskommt also da wo die
Verwaltungsbehörden geänderte Briefe
schreiben da wo die Universitäten
Schüler und Studenten dazu verpflichten
zu Gendern in ihren Abschlussarbeiten
und sonst Noten Abzüge androhen da geht
das nicht und blackfacing das Beispiel
das jetzt gerade für großen Aufruhr
sorgt aus Hessen ist das für sie okay ja
das muss man sich das muss man sich
anschauen wieder wie das im Einzelfall
gemacht wird also wenn sich jetzt
jemanden
kann man sehen wie das gemacht wurde ich
sag jetzt mal meins wäre es nicht ähm
das muss man für sich selbst entscheiden
ob man ob man so rumlaufen will und ob
man dafür nicht möglicherweise Gefühle
von anderen Menschen verletzt ähm ich
glaube ein bisschen mehr Sensibilität
bei vielen Sachen würden uns gut tun
also das ist für andere Menschen
unangenehm sein kann das Geschehen sie
zu Herr Fleischer und sie wo sehen sie
sehen sie Gefahren sie leben in Spanien
ist es vielleicht auch eine Diskussion
die man im Blick von außen wie in
Deutschland besonders intensiv führen
nein also es wird auch in der spanischen
Sprache versucht zu Gendern was
schwerer möglich ist als im Deutschen
ich wollte dazu noch sagen
ich habe ja Sprachen studiert und mir
fällt da kein Vorteil auf
JournalistInnen
Journalistinnen und Journalisten und so
weiter und so fort also das ist meine
persönliche Meinung dazu und ich habe
mit großem Interesse dem
Psychotherapeuten Bonelli gelauscht der
hier neulich zu Gast war der gesagt hat
dass die wokners sozusagen der die
letzte Äußerung eines Narzissmus
moralischen Narzissmus das fand ich sehr
treffend also sozusagen als ein Symptom
einer Gesellschaft mit der irgendwas
nicht stimmt ja also das
erscheint mir ziemlich interessante
nicht mit unserer Gesellschaft so ein
bisschen ihre These sie sagen der geht
auch eine Gefahr von aus da geht davon
die Gefahr aus dass er immer mehr wir
uns Spalten also ich glaube was was
willst du nächstes Mal sehen ist das
eigentlich fast keine dieser Maßnahmen
den gewünschten Effekt hatte den sie
eigentlich hätte haben sollen also weder
sind jetzt die Straßen in Berlin
sicherer durch so einen Katalog noch
haben wir uns besonders beliebt gemacht
im Ausland mit der Aktion in Katar die
auch ein bisschen so ein rohrkrippierer
war und was mich halt vor allem auch
stört das ist oft so sind dann immer so
Bekenntnisse ab dem gar keine Taten
folgen aber man man stellt sich dann
beispielsweise als besonders gutes
Unternehmen da indem man jetzt irgendwie
eine Regenbogenflagge vor die Tür stellt
und dann guckt man irgendwie das
Unternehmen rein dann stellt man fest
aha da werden jetzt wieder irgendwie so
und so viel Jobs abgebrochen weil da
vielleicht um uns irgendwelchen
Investoren rechts zu machen also ich
glaube das das Problem ist ich mit
dieser ganzen Sache habe es wirklich
diese dass wir uns da dass sie über
Themen diskutieren die eigentlich für
den Großteil der Menschen überhaupt gar
nicht relevant sind und da würde ich
gerne zurück ich würde auch gerne zurück
dahin dass ich linke Parteien wieder um
soziale Fragen kümmern und nicht um die
Frage wie ich eine Frage formulieren
muss damit sich vermeintlich niemand
verletzt fühlt sich beides kann man sich
nicht um die Inhalte kümmern Viktor und
dennoch um die Form der Darstellung das
ganze ist wie ein Pendel glaube ich das
hin und her schwingt und im Moment sind
wir an dem Punkt das haben Sie auch
schon gesagt wo das Panel sozusagen am
weitesten nach außen schlägt und wir
Herr Christel da stimme Ihnen zu
wirklich Erfolge Absurditäten haben aber
Patricia und deine Frage zu beantworten
ob beides geht ich weiß es nicht was ist
denn zum Beispiel mit Dreadlocks ja es
wird jetzt gesagt weiße Leute sollen
keine Dreadlocks mehr haben sie haben
das alle mitgekriegt da wurde eine weiße
Sängerin die auf einem Wolken Festival
auftreten sollte Last Minute
rausgeschmissen weil sie Dreadlocks
hatte und dann wurde gesagt das ist
jetzt kulturelle Aneignung und dann hat
die aber gesagt nein nein meine
Vorfahren sind Wikinger und die hatten
auch drecks und deswegen ist es aber
doch wieder in Ordnung ja und jetzt also
es passt hinten und vorne nicht wissen
was ich meine wo ist er gerade für sie
der Gradmesser dass man sagt das ist
eine gesellschaftliche Weiterentwicklung
weil wir uns weiterentwickeln und wo
beginnt für sie der Punkt dass sie sagen
das wird irgendwie absurd das verlieren
wir eventuell auch Menschen können Sie
diese diesen Punkt irgendwo zu machen
also ich glaube man kann es man kann es
an der Historie auch klar klar
festmachen irgendwie beispielsweise
Frauenwahlrecht ja das ist natürlich
absoluter Fortschritt ja jetzt aber
quasi überall Sexismus zu wittern ist es
vielleicht halt nicht oder wenn man sagt
man man ist Sexismus gewittert also
diese Diskussion die werden teilweise
führen über irgendwelche
bikini-werbungen oder so weil die gehen
mir einfach echt ein Stück zu weit und
da wird dann auch irgendwie auch auf
Frauen im jetzt bin ich natürlich der
Frauenbeauftragte und schwierig
irgendwie finden Geschlecht zu sprechen
nämlich angehöre aber da wird dann
Frauen dann auch so ein bisschen
irgendwie einfach das Recht genommen
irgendwie sich selber auch irgendwie
sich selber zu entscheiden
fotografieren oder was mache ich oder
schminke ich mich oder schminke ich
nicht oder oder bleibe ich lieber zu
Hause oder gehe ich lieber arbeiten ich
liebe Karriere wenn ich lieber
Hausfrauen Mutter ich finde dass sie
doch dann muss doch allen Lebens
Entwürfen die die die wir so haben doch
die Möglichkeit geben dass sich diese
Lebens Entwürfe einigermaßen ja dann
frei bewegen können und auch frei leben
können das ist doch lieber daran
arbeiten
ein bisschen was einzuschreiten oder bei
denen schon wieder irgendwas
einzuschränken weil das jetzt wiederum
nicht irgendeinem Zeitgeist und dann
vermeintlichen Zeitgeist entspricht das
ist ja mit der freien Entfaltung der
Persönlichkeit wieso darf ich denn meine
Haare nicht als Zopf machen oder aber
dann dürfen sie auch nicht Blackface
essen also das ist dann werde Moral ins
Bett legt was mit Doppelmoral aus frei
ich will einfach meine Persönlichkeit
frei entfalten und wenn ich der Meinung
bin ich muss mit dem Rock rumlennen und
mit einem was weiß ich regenschirmhut
oder sowas warum denn nicht machen das
müssen Sie gar nicht sie müssen jetzt
keinen Rock der beruhigen
dürfen
also ich rate bei diesen ganzen Thema
auch immer zu etwas mehr Gelassenheit ja
und vielleicht in Diskussion nicht immer
dem anderen immer dass das schlechteste
zu unterstellen also nicht jemandem der
jetzt nicht gendert zu unterstellen dass
er irgendwie Frauen überhaupt nicht mit
meint oder
dritte Geschlechter nicht anerkennt oder
sowas das ist wirklich ein bisschen mehr
Gelassenheit ein bisschen respektvoll
miteinander dann kommen wir weiter aber
was ist denn damit der CDU und der
frauenqu dass da so hin und her gerungen
wurde bis der Mann Ergebnis da war ja da
haben wir diskutiert in der Partei und
der Parteitag hat eine Entscheidung
getroffen und die gilt jetzt für